zendaya is sending love to her boyfriend
tom holland on his 26th birthday i just
feel very lucky
that's really all i always kind of say
zee shared this rare black and white
photo of the two together tom looks into
the camera while he holds the actress
close as she flashes a grin looking out
of the frame
zendaya's sweet caption happiest of
birthdays to the one who makes me the
happiest tom's response three heart
emojis it's just the beginning of this
really adorable
romance that we're watching kind of
bloom on camera
i really like you
i really like you too
the pair haven't been shy about sharing
their adoration for each other on the
gram back in september tom posted a
birthday tribute of his own wishing zia
happy 25th with this cozy
behind-the-scenes pick can we just like
stay up here all day it is so crazy down
there tom wearing his spidey suit as
zendaya stands behind him taking the
candid snap herself
referring to z's character in the film
tom wrote in the caption my mj have the
happiest of birthdays give me a call
when you're up very sweet post from tom
what was it like to see the post and uh
i noticed you commented calling now
no it's i mean i i am yeah i was it was
sweet i guess i don't know
um
um yeah no i um i appreciated you know
the love that i got from my loved ones
and then also from you know the world it
was i felt incredibly loved and grateful
for for all of that so you know i have
no complaints it was a great birthday
and now i'm here so
not bad of course hints of a romance
between the co-stars swirled around for
years before confirming their
relationship of course you know we we
expected it i mean it's um it comes with
the territory it comes with the job so
it's all good and dating rumors really
started heating up last july when tom
and zendaya were photographed kissing in
a car that's pictures of you and tom and
people were so excited because they're
like spider-man it's real like it was
like the world was rooting for this
moment well i'm i'm excited for the film
to come out i can't wait for everybody
to see um spider-man when it does come
out and you know we we all work so hard
we're all so you know we're all so close
from that fast forward to november and
spidey himself officially confirmed
their relationship to gq some suggest
that parker's powers include the male
spider's ability to hypnotize females
stop come on yes my spider lord yeah and
the hypnotizing works in real life too
like when z stopped tom and his tracks
at the spider-man no way home premiere
how are you feeling about that and
tackling that they're losing things i
think zendaya just sounds like they're
just showed up
[Music]
that's her and for zendaya she's just
happy to have tom in her corner i think
it's it's great to have that support and
that love around you because you need
that you know this isn't an easy easy
job so it's good to have
that to to free you up from it every now
and then
[Music]